united airlines is out with a plan
pushing diversity for new pilots
the company wants to train 5 000 of them
over the next decade
and is promising at least half will be
women or people of color
united would also be taking on
applicants with no flying experience
which means i'm there i'm there i'm
going to go to you first
pete because you're the cl you look like
you're a pilot
i feel like when i get on a plane you're
the person this is that
what how sexist is that no it's also
it's like the pilot
it's sexist and racist but you know what
the thing is pete i don't think this is
a bad goal
this doesn't sound bad to me it's just
that you never should tamper with the
system
like or lower a standard to reach to
reach the numbers you want isn't that
just common sense
i agree uh you don't want me flying
anything greg i would love to fly with
you
uh i i i wouldn't put my life in your
hands in that situation but
here's what i here's what i want to work
by 23rd i want my wi-fi to work i want
them to lose my
bag less i want less delays and i want
to get to where i'm going quicker
i want i want everyone every plane to
stay in the sky regardless of whether
the pilot is a male or female and the
passengers are males or females it
doesn't matter to me what's the best
business decision
for united and that's not what's going
into this and here's the problem it's
gonna be a nice goal greg as you talked
about i'm all for
people from different back but my
experience with bureaucracies or big
companies is that once you send a quota
or a percentage
meeting that quota becomes more
important than the performance goals and
the outcomes and pretty soon you start
hedging on
who qualifies who doesn't did they pass
this did they not piss past that
regardless of gender and skin color and
all of that that's not where you want to
be focused you want the best people
especially when it comes to getting
people from a to b in the air
you shouldn't be me but um i i don't
know if i agree completely with you pete
because kennedy i think that like
obviously they the people that are
making this decision
have already thought about this right
it's like they're not gonna like there's
nobody in a i can't believe there'd be
somebody in a board room that would go
you know what
let's lower that you know let's they
really don't have to be great pilots
let's get some people in here
i don't think anybody's actually gonna
say it's like sir it's like you wouldn't
do that with a surgeon
no but that's that's a that's a great
comparison because
there are objective requirements to
surgery and to flying a plane
right you know there are other like
being a painter
or an actor those have more subjective
qualities and and that i understand
and this is where you truly want to be
colorblind because you want people to
meet those standards
i fly i've flown 70 000 miles on united
this year i am a very loyal
united passenger make me global services
by the way and this is ridiculous
uh what i will say when i get on a plane
and i hear
a female pilot come on board it it gives
me great comfort because i think that
she's gi jane or lady maverick
and has competed against the guys and
has worked twice as hard for half the
credit
and has risen through the ranks to to
fly a massive plane
uh so i i actually like that part i
don't recognize gender in
voice kennedy so uh when i hear i just
hear a voice
uh juan um what do you think is this is
this uh
anything surprising or i don't know
interesting i just think it's good news
greg i mean to me
you know i you know safety is number one
any airlines that doesn't
operate a safe airlines is a is going
out of business
and what we got right now is i think
it's last year two percent of all pilots
uh were black but only five percent were
women
i mean what why women have brains and
ability i don't know why a woman can't
fly an airplane to me
part of this issue is that both the
military and commercial aviation
is overwhelmingly a white and male
occupation and i think it's just time to
open up the doors
you know every pilot everybody you know
beginning
starts with no-flight experience so just
give people an opportunity
you know dana i know this doesn't apply
to you because you fly privately
wherever you go
all right and uh um but do you i can't
reach the pedals
yeah the pedals there are no pedals
you know can we all just agree that the
airline industry is racist
oh yeah i'm good absolutely and also
josh earnest if you're listening please
make kennedy global services it's the
least
you can do come on help her out and buy
the sister out here's the big secret
the pilots don't even fly the planes
computers fly planes that that's why
they can do this and
they can have like you know redheads and
morbidly obese people
and you know those are the people who
are who are really uh
they feel the the most oppressiveness in
society
yes i want more diversity in the
bathrooms
the fastest is up next i don't